[Music]
so these two teenagers in New York City
in a subway
they decided it'd be hilarious to do
this idiot
eat a piece of stupid idiot what do they
do I have no idea but the way she
presented it coronavirus pretty much
reminder don't move your heads here we
go
I will [ __ ] Amon that's such a weak-ass
suit [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
then what would they do that it's a
prank bro I would grab that and dump it
on them
there's people laughing it's obvious
like a prank I know but I hate prints
like this yeah that's the detriment of
other people why would they think that
coronavirus looks like strawberry soda
it's actually kool-aid
well whatever it's like that's not how
the [ __ ] [ __ ] works you understand
yeah it's not a liquid they did prank
some people believe it so yeah stupid
dude don't drink the corona but Hurst
juice I know yeah oh yeah so they're
just saying that those pranksters are 17
and 19 years old and they were just
trying to get a laugh I mean they did
end up telling people immediately but
then it's a prank it's a prank but that
could have been a grandmother had a
heart attack you're just I don't know I
just don't like this stuff well I think
it's funnier if they did that and then
the whole train turning around and [ __ ]
their ass that would have been a funny
prank
I want a little lesson then hey you guys
are all scared of coronavirus yeah so
then they did mention that there's this
mom in her kids next to them and that
they figured out immediately that they
were like all these [ __ ] are up to
something so by the time they did it all
like they're just laughing they're like
oh yeah
yeah I'd say a teenager thought that it
was it was [ __ ] because like this is
a like a world thing now so there's no
way that they're just gonna have these
[ __ ] on a train with a corona virus
like it's too many ways of travel for
you to just be on a train with this
biohazard disease well and this kid
looks like he just started shaving
he's got a bunch of pimples on his face
his voice keeps cracking we're like
you're not a scientist babysitting going
like this every time there's someone
recording the whole thing yeah I mean
come on no some people on Twitter we're
like dude this is not funny and you
better have cleaned your [ __ ] after you
left I would have been more disturbed
and upset about the mess that they may
use right like so I have to walk on that
now my shoes are gonna be sitting on the
stairs
[Laughter]
walking up the steps of New York
everybody like now I gotta hear that
[ __ ] take my shoes off before going down
there's the whole thing that's what I
would have been upset about right there
we got clean that [ __ ] up BAM ya got
anything everybody give them napkins
right now voice oh you have an
intimidating listen the thought of voice
yeah you know that's cause you worked in
the jails no I'm also dead does the dad
make you more daddy-o I pull my pants up
when I'm rapping mintu my daughter my
head my parents are like right here pull
them all the way in it what the [ __ ] did
I say about these dishes
oh yeah falls on one side of your
pathway home I build I vacuum oh no
laughing I'm a lefty that's part of the
intimidation what'd you think was
intimating about it okay I thought that
like your base like hid my soul oh man
my daughter hates when I read cuz I
don't I don't really raised my voice
ever so like it's only been a couple
times and I've had to raise my voice
where happen what I do like I can tell
it [ __ ] with her I'll yell at my wife
in my head yeah well that's smart that
helps you got to be careful yelling at
your wife because she knows where you
live yeah I don't yell about sleep love
that too I mean that's kind of part of
where you live you sleep their time I'm
like yelling at people anymore this is
sleep well yeah because his eyes are
[ __ ] closed which means he's extra
vulnerable where he does where he lives
it's the point that I was making that's
all I was saying I still go see
yes you're right you're right but you're
right - you're right - that's not you
that's how you win guys just know you're
right yeah that's only the way I was
wrong
Betty it doesn't always we'll see that
part did you see how you wind up I was
taking notes and I learned [ __ ] happy
wife happy life
yeah but sometimes they win and they
have a [ __ ] parade about it for like
eight hours really that's what you guys
do - well I know because I fig really
get to have a parade or you could be
seeing Hojo yeah come on Playboy okay
what's that have a heart let me know
okay bad [ __ ] alert oh okay it got
weird but I just made it really weird
you buy me in today part of this thing
yeah [ __ ] those kids up man always tells
but it always comes back to [ __ ] the
kids the dick you run over by the
railroad hopefully know these kids [ __ ]
these kids [ __ ] kids so their prank
wasn't like that crazy because there's
this other dude who was an artist
I hate these [ __ ] man and so
this dude in the past he was in a flight
and he stood up he's like can I get
everyone's attention please little waves
new album just drop so everyone should
go listen to it or some [ __ ] and then
that video went viral so then this time
he thought oh I could get another viral
video so he stands up midway through the
flight he he pulls out his camera and
then he ends up saying that he's like I
just came from Hunan Province in China
woo ha no no he said Hunan you're right
because oh he said no he said whoo not
because he thought it'd be funny to say
Hunan and people think he came from
Wuhan and then to kind of make fun of
how ignorant Americans are I see and
then so they had to dock the plane and
like quarantine it anyway all this
issues there were like over 200 people
that car was going
Jamaica or some fun vacation to Jamaica
that sucks man oh we turn around and
this will yeah he he got around me would
and you know like I said Hunan like not
Wuhan the wave it's done up and say yeah
okay that you just came from China right
now bro period that's the whole [ __ ]
thing that's okay now that's one that's
too far there right so yeah this you
know be a pretty bad but funny prank so
like get like a toilet and in like like
set it up in a train and just take a
[ __ ] with the newspaper and they go oh
no no no he's gonna give it bathtub and
some way and then take a shower in the
back the tables on us on a sub yeah I
like that and he's doing a game with the
girl he did one with the tub he was
actually immature and reading like a
ball like the tub lining I guess I'm a
hardware store he was literally intended
to reading the newspapers here so he and
he sets up the table yeah just like okay
anybody doesn't freak people out yeah
it's also not a great bit yeah I know I
look at the girls too and I'm like come
on you I'm sure you've already seen this
you don't know what's gonna happen they
don't know what's gonna happen so I'm
like alright you don't like the team so
maybe it's not as big over there London
it's huge over here but London is like
he sits next to a girl right and then he
starts he brings out a little table and
then he puts a cloth on it and then he
puts a candle and then he starts like
setting it up as a date and you have
champagne glasses and then he'll pour
champagne the girl like completely
unsuspecting and she's just like what
the [ __ ]
and she's like trying not to laugh but
he's like about it like like yeah what
time you had a grill
yeah the grill set up Hey and left home
without it could but yeah put it off the
grill or like that was good I
I wonder if they continue like a
friendship or relationship after that
like does he actually get her number and
then they like he's definitely [ __ ]
absolutely
cuz that's some pretty next-level [ __ ]
you would do your prank stuff I didn't
never tell anybody was a prank
oh you're not getting laid after the
prank no really maybe one time I did
because I was doing a thing outside of
the chick-fil-a and this gig I got
pretty [ __ ] pissed and then but the
whole bit was that I'm like hey gay
people can you please sign this petition
saying like or sign this contract that
says like if we give you guys gay
marriage you guys aren't gonna take it
past that I could just leave it at gay
marriage please don't start marrying
animals all stuff right oh my god like
that's what people [ __ ] thinking it's
a slippery slope because they think that
if gay marriage is past well duh man
it's gonna be like pitiful yeah so
that's what I was just playing the role
of the dumbasses and I'm like yo I'm so
like when he was he was like really
upset right and I don't blame him at all
and then after the video was over I was
like yo man I'm with you like that's the
whole point of video he's like oh my god
I get it okay like it was like that cuz
I was telling him I was like yo dude
like if I'm walking by your house you
gotta close your windows if you're gonna
be paying about his boyfriend we're I
can't I can't there's a way to turn it
deescalate things as they're happening
that that but yeah my first prank videos
out here I the barbershop that I I went
to they were they were fans of mine so
they let me use the barbershop and when
people were coming in I was telling them
that it's a new barber shops are the new
management and you actually have to buy
a booth to get into the barber shop and
I had all the soup with the clipboard
numbers like they walk up like hey man
what's up can I help you up
say yeah let's get a burger like did you
reserve a booth because we're already
doing haircuts with the boob you got the
accent get a bottle now you know the
girls come bring it out to you it's like
what like yeah it's kind of kind of do
things on new management [ __ ] like that
people $300 right here
I'll say like a hundred fifty so you got
some saying where it's like that's so
obvious but people don't even know I was
like yo you guys are gonna take this the
point where you start like Mary and
patio furniture are you like that and
this guy still gets Pez it's like oh no
okay but well you're emotional about
something in care about gonna see all
that yeah I also like dressing in all
black and act like I'm security whatever
like we were on tour two years ago and a
guy I guess if he was familiar with me
and what does girls every that is a calf
so they come in and give their tickets
and we got the birthday boys right here
and I was just standing I was like you
know my man I gotta fetch it down real
quick you take a look at your products
it sells it and then one of the people
wore Gerber say was like he's a comic
he's not even security and I was looking
up I just gotta run away no I like that
one
[Music]